ich bin mir übrigens gar nicht so sicher
ob ich heute arbeiten darf denn überall
in Deutschland wird gestreikt im
öffentlichen Dienst an Flughäfen am
Dienstag letzten Dienstag sogar beim ZDF
haben sie gar nicht gemerkt ne kein
gutes Zeichen wenn es keiner merkt
wer die ruft heute bundesweit zu
Warnstreiks im Krankenhäusern auf und
bei der Post droht jetzt sogar ein
unbefristeter Streik poststreik ja das
Ergebnis der Urabstimmung
dazu muss man jenseits von Post
Angelegenheiten wissen die deutschen
Arbeitnehmer insgesamt haben 2022 das
dritte Jahr in Folge weniger reale und
bekommen als im Jahr davor er ist doch
kein Wunder dass Dinge jetzt langsam mal
reicht wie diese aktuellen Bilder
beweisen es ging um 15% und mehr die
Preisentwicklung heizt die Stimmung an
mit schlagkräftigen Parolen und
feuchtfröhlichen knüppelversen
begleiteten die Mitglieder der
Gewerkschaften die Vorbereitungen zur
urabstimmen
mit Parolen und Knittel Fersen ach das
waren Beitrag von 1974 aber gar nicht
gemerkt oder ja heute haben wir ja
wieder Inflation und der Gesetzgeber
findet es offenbar völlig okay das
Vermieter an diese Inflation gekoppelte
rasant steigende indexmieten kassiert
aber bei Gewerkschaften wird Lohn
Zurückhaltung gepredigt nur wegen der
bösen lohnen Preisspirale zur Erinnerung
da streiken gerade viele für die wir in
den Corona ja noch geklatscht haben vom
Balkon jeden Abend Kita Personal
Pflegekräfte Müllabfuhr kurz gesagt
systemrelevante Branchen wie die hier
die reine Schwester seelischen
Brauereien das ist zum Beispiel die
Diebels in Issum die DAB in Dortmund die
streiken heute auch also Pilz alt und
Kölsch gemeinsam wir vereint
nein man muss es nacheinander trinken
erst wenn die letzte pilzbrauerei
streikt werdet Ihr merken dass man
Kölsch nicht trinken kann
Applaus in einem Kölner Studio an der
Stelle so fast alles fast alles was
Arbeitnehmer heute für ganz
selbstverständlich halten wurde über die
Jahre erstreckt umso besser dass die
Tarifbindung weiter zurückgeht das
Streikrecht ist ein Grundrecht der
Arbeitnehmer klar nervenstreiks auch mal
aber deswegen stellt man ja nicht gleich
da Streikrecht an sich in Frage es sei
denn man ist in der mittelstandsunion
weil sensiblen Bereichen muss zunächst
ein verbindliches Schlichtungsverfahren
vorgeschaltet werden es braucht eine
Ankündigungsfrist und es muss eine
Notversorgung sichergestellt sein
richtig Frau Connemann gerade gesehen in
ihrem kamin-kostüm fordert fordert das
Streikrecht Leid also man dürfte wenn es
nach ihr geht schon noch streiten aber
so dass es keiner merkt ne also ihre
Idealvorstellung sieht wohl so aus alle
Arbeiten einfach wie gewohnt weiter und
wer Lust hat kann ja nach Feierabend
einfach noch ein bisschen auf dem
Parkplatz vor der Firma streiken wenn es
wirklich sein muss ausdrücklich erlaubt
wäre virtuelle streiken über Teams da
schlage ich dann aber nicht selber
sondern nur mein Avatar
Idee kann die mittelstandsunion nicht
mal streiken das finde ich toll und
Dieter Connemann gibt keine Interviews
mehr 20 Prozent der
Vollzeitbeschäftigten bei uns in
Deutschland 20 Prozent verdienen
2500 Brutto oder weniger im Osten sind
es sogar unglaubliche 32 Prozent so und
in dieser Gemengelage meldet sich jetzt
Steffen campeter vom Arbeitgeberverband
BDA und sagt mal was hier das
eigentliche Problem ist mehr Einsatz
gleich 39 Stunden statt womöglich 4 Tage
Woche verlangt der Arbeitgeberverband
kurz mehr Bock auf Arbeit
ja so nämlich nicht weniger arbeiten
mehr Bock ne diesem Land Film Böcke
kann Peter der sympathische Mann hier zu
sehen an der galerenttrommel
macht sich Sorgen weil wir Bürger durch
die ganzen Rettungspakete und doppelwse
vergessen hätten das Zitat kam Peter
Geld auch erwirtschaftet werden muss wir
sind quasi von Olaf Scholz in die
bocklosigkeit reingewummst worden
wollen seitdem nur noch Freizeit das war
nämlich der Anfang vom Ende meine Damen
und der Anfang vom Ende für unseren
Wirtschaftsstandort die Erfindung der
Verdammten Work-Life-Balance und die ist
tatsächlich schon vor 100.000 Jahren
erfunden worden in der sogenannten
Generation Steinzeit da hatte ein
Düsseldorfer Neandertaler Namen genagt
plötzlich keinen Bock mehr auf
Säbelzahntiger jagen er hat mehrere vom
Jobcenter bezahlte Umschulung gemacht
erst zum
höhlenmaler dann zum Mammut Milch
Barista aber nur halbtags den Rest der
Zeit hat damit Duftkerzen gechillt und
als knack dann noch die Idee hatte man
könnte doch Mammuts genauso gut aus dem
Höhlen Office Person jagen sind sie
leider ausgestorben
übrigens sehr leicht zu erklären warum
Herr kamp-peter so auf dem Kriegs hat
ist weil gerade über die vier Tage Woche
diskutiert wird alle reden über die vier
Tage Woche und jetzt könnte man
einwenden Gott ist auch nicht nach vier
Tagen Schöpfung ins Wochenende gegangen
stimmt aber der Wald auch in keiner
Gewerkschaft in England haben 61 Firmen
die vier Tage Woche ausprobiert Ergebnis
weniger Fehlzeiten bei den Mitarbeitern
und die Produktivität ist gleich
geblieben oder sogar gestiegen 56
britische Unternehmen machen jetzt
freiwillig weiter und auch deutsche
kommen zunehmend auf den vier Tage
Geschmack freitags hat man halben Tag
dann fährt man auf die Baustelle da
packt das Werkzeug aus dann ist es
meistens schon 8:30 Uhr müssen wir dann
in die Gänge kommt ist Frühstück
dass man dann wirklich in ins
arbeitsgenosster dann ist schon mal
zusammen fahren nach Hause
Memo an mich selbst
freitags keine Handwerker mehr bestellen
ja gut vier Tage Woche funktioniert
natürlich nicht für jede Branche ist ja
völlig logisch trotzdem sind manche
abwehrenden Reaktionen aus der Politik
schon verwunderlich ein gewisser Markus
Söder zum Beispiel sagt Fußballer würden
ja auch nicht nach 80 Minuten in die
Kabine gehen
doch wenn sie Scheiße spielen werden sie
ausgewechselt oder lieber Markus eben
abgewählt ne der Markus die Arbeitswelt
verändert sich und dazu gehört auch dass
wir lernen mit Streiks zu leben in
Frankreich ist eine Meldung wenn man
einen Tag nicht gestreikt wird
warum zittern jetzt schon wieder alle
vor dem nächsten Bahnstreik ich bleibe
in jedem Fall solidarisch während der
Arbeitgeberverband BDA weiter auf mehr
Box setzt Bock statt Burnout ja alles
klar ja kann ich sie gleich zurückrufen
hier ist gerade sehr viel los okay danke
schön danke schön
kannst du mal bitte rangehen
sie arbeiten in einem kleinen
Unternehmen aber nur in Teilzeit weil
sie eine zweijährige Tochter haben und
es in Ihrer Gegend keine
Ganztagsbetreuung gibt ja geht halt
nicht anders und sie machen sich jetzt
schon Sorgen weil sie wegen Teilzeit
später kaum Rente kriegen ja deswegen
mache ich mir Sorgen logisch zu Recht
aber wir vom BDA haben die perfekte
Lösung und die heißt Bock du musst
einfach mehr Bock drauf arbeiten haben
was ja klar Bock auf Arbeit auf randlose
sonst geht das Land hier vor die Hunde
und du bist schuld ne und dann hätte
Putin gewonnen oder bist du vielleicht
für Putin wieso ziehen ich hatte Bock
auf bessere Kinderbetreuung und warum
bekommt der Idiot für die gleiche Arbeit
mehr Geld als ich wenn der mehr Geld
kriegt dann hat er besser verhandelt
weil er mehr Bock hatte als du und eine
Penis
unsere Aktion mehr Bock auf Arbeit
endlich anpacken statt Gejaule ganz
genau und nimm die Arbeit mit nach Hause
und bespaße gleichzeitig kein Kind weil
dein Mann eine wichtige Fernsehsendung
gucken muss
und du hast Bock auf Arbeit habe ich
überhaupt nicht gar nicht so ich arbeite
nur nach Feierabend weil wir sonst
unsere fucking Indexmiete nicht bezahlen
können ich höre nur immer ich ich ja
mache jetzt mit bei unserer Aktion ich
habe Bock auf Arbeit und Gewinn ein
cooles T-Shirt und jetzt war eine ganz
andere Frage warum müssen Kinder
eigentlich immer betreut werden die
kleine hier die kann laufen hat zwei
gesunde Arme mit anderen Worten Pizza
austragen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so Aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische endcard
von Oliver Welke und der heute-show
leider ist das Video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den Kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres Video
anschauen vielen Dank so müsste jetzt
für immer reichen